[Music]  new tonight the company right at the  center of a social media firestorm over  video showing a cat being kicked  speaking out  about the situation it's just been we've  got  death threats it's non-stop uh calls and  emails and  texts and people have gotten a hold of  our pictures and our families and  they're saying it's my son  it's not none of that's true now a  warning tonight for what is  really intense video you're about to see  it happen last month in centennial hills  shows a man wearing a williams pest  control shirt kick  that cat now we know the cat is doing  fine the company says the man  is not the owner's son they want to  clarify that as some has said on social  media  they say he was a sales trainee and he  no longer works for the company  they also reaffirmed that williams pest  control doesn't tolerate  any form of abuse